dois je sais pas si les hamsters court
très vite mais nous allons le savoir
grâce à jacques très malins qui va nous
raconter une histoire d'âme star a déjà
dû vous raconter les enfants
autrefois on connaissait un seul
abstraire un villa hamster gris qui
habite en alsace et en allemagne qu'on
détestait parce qu'il fait des stocks
énormes dans son terrier on trouvait 60
81 kg de grains alors reprocher quand il
a mis l'homme à terre dans un champ et
reste plus grand chose dans le met pas
et puis en 1838 il ya un savant nommé
waterhouse qui dans le désert de syrie
là bas hu a un petit hamster doré comme
celui que vous connaissez comme les vole
un seul il le voit il le regarde il
comprend pas il le décrit richard à son
temps après en 1930 un savant
d'alexandrie le professeur à à ronnie va
dans le même désert ils cherchaient des
scorpions lui le court après un scorpion
ratzel scorpions creusent la terre brad
rapide en scorpion et tombe dans un trou
sur une mer hamster et ses douze petits
c'était des hamsters dorés comme les
routes c'est dire le cerf d'or il vous
connaissez tous vous avez tous vu j'y
tiens c'est l'animal waterhouse avait
découvert ce formidable email tout dans
un panier rentrer chez lui et said élevé
ces hamsters la plupart crève et il en
envoie 4 au professeur adler à londres
au muséum de loin au british muséum pour
étudier la ville ces petits hamsters là
les savants se penche sur ces hamsters
les études il regarde comment sa vie
combien de temps sa porte avant tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur hamster du moins
il le seul figure seulement eu hamster
ça se reproduit et à la cadence de six
petits tous les trois mois au bout de
deux ans le british muséum était plat de
hamster c'est plus qu'en faire
heureusement il y avait les gardes du
british muséum il y avait les
professeurs qui avaient des enfants les
gosses de votre âge qui avaient vu ces
hamsters qu'ils aiment c'est joli comme
tout hamster donnez le nous on leur
donne des petits hamsters et les enfants
commencent à étudier le hamster il
découvre sur le mc oran tas de choses
comme ça qu'on n'avait jamais vu par
exemple que un hamster on peut le
prendre comme on veut quand il a la
bouche pleine vous savez il transporte
ses provisions dans sa bouche à lui fait
des grosses gouttes alors quand il a les
joues pleines comme ça on peut le
prendre le car et c'est cette faille
c'est très facile mais quand il a vidé
sa bouche avec ses pattes parce qu'ils
la vident avec ses pattes il vaut mieux
faire attention parce qu'il pourrait
peut-être vous mordre et puis découvre
aussi que le hamster est un véritable
pitre mais un pitre quand vous l'avez un
petit hamster dans vingt ans dans sa
cage où il y en ait une petite chaise
une petite échelle un tourniquet comme
aux écureuils mais vraiment il fait le
clown mais littéralement pour vous
amuser comme s'il faisait exprès et
voilà que les gosses qui raconte ses
histoires sur les hamsters et tout le
monde avait les histoires de abstrait
pour la suisse devront se disent mais
non d'un chien ses enfants il y avait à
ce moment là des millions le hamster à
travers l'angleterre et la france l'ont
été tous connus des hamsters bon et
savants se disait d'un chien ces gars
sont vus sur le hamster beaucoup plus de
choses que nous n'avions découverte nous
si on allait voir au désert les vrais
hamster les hamsters sauvage comment il
faut aussi gens aussi intelligents que
ce que les gosses raconte comprenez pour
comprendre s'il s'était l'éducation tout
ceci c'est naturel
on part on le désert de syrie là où le
professeur aarau n'y avait trouvé ses
treize hamster on trouve pas on
quadrille le désert mais on le parti
vert allemand au peigne fin on a pu
trouver un seul abstrait les treize
hamster que le professeur a à ronnie
avait découvert en 1930 et elle est
dernier de l'espèce et l'espèce qui
compte maintenant des millions et des
millions de l'aps terre a été
littéralement sauvé parce que vous les
gosses vous avez élevé rehab ster et
vous avez appris à jouer avec le gardien
sont des gens absolument charmant merci
jacques très malin